okay so some of the questions we've been
asking about the robert muller
investigation into trump russia have
been how much longer is it going to go
on we've heard claims of it being almost
over dating all the way back to 2017 and
we've heard from acting Attorney General
Matthew Whitaker last week in that very
bizarre and sweaty statement that he
gave that he also believes it's about to
end and the question that I increasingly
have been asking is if it's true that
this investigation is almost done why
was there a morning FBI raid last week
on Roger stone would that really be the
last thing that would happen in such a
massive investigation or do you do that
because you don't want him to destroy
evidence about future possible indict
ease so I don't believe that we are that
close to the end of the probe the next
question that we also have to ask about
the probe is what ever happened to
Donald Trump jr. being in trouble he
said he expected to be indicted he is
potentially in trouble for a whole bunch
of different stuff including false
statements made to the House
Intelligence Committee for his
involvement in that Trump Tower meeting
there's a whole bunch of suspicion
surrounding Donald Trump jr. we've
actually heard from congresswoman Jackie
Speier that she believes Donald Trump
jr. lied to the house Intel committee at
least twice that is something people are
getting in trouble for Michael Cohen
Roger stone both charged for making
false statements to the House
Intelligence Committee so that's a
serious thing that even within this
particular investigation people have
been getting indicted for and what we've
been wondering is well if we heard that
Donald Trump jr. was going to get
indicted months ago and it hasn't
happened what happened to that was that
fake news if there are no charges
supposedly this quote late in the
investigation is it possible that there
simply aren't going to be any charges
against Donald Trump jr. we may be
starting to get the answer because it
appears as though robert muller
is only this week going to get the
official transcripts of Donald Trump jr.
and Jared Kushner by the way of their
testimony
to the House Intelligence Committee
tomorrow Wednesday February 6th the
House Intelligence Committee has
scheduled a vote that vote will be on
the quote transmission of certain
committee transcripts to the Department
of Justice okay the question as to
exactly which transcripts is one that we
don't have a 100% clear answer to there
are something like 70 something
witnesses that have testified before the
House Intelligence Committee any of
those could be the ones that the house
is voting on but of course Donald Trump
jr. and Jared Kushner's transcripts are
pretty close to the top of the list in
terms of what might be interesting to
robert muller and to the Justice
Department
there's also Trump's bodyguard there's
Trump's 2016 digital media director Brad
parse Cal who's running Trump's 20/20
campaign there's that mercenary
billionaire who happens to be Betsy
Davis's brother Eric prints hope Hicks
one of trumps many White House
communications directors Russian
oligarch Felix aider testified there's a
whole bunch of interesting transcripts
that could be headed over to robert
muller and the ones that could be the
biggest would be Donald Trump jr. and
Jared Kushner jr. in particular because
he has again said he is fearing an
indictment now there is this
counterpoint which is well these are the
official transcripts but the content of
these testimonies has been made
available to robert muller already so
why would it really make a difference if
he gets the official transcripts and
that's a very very good question I'm
glad you asked the reason it's important
is that you need those official
transcripts to attach to the indictments
with Roger stone in December the
official transcripts were sent over to
rot to a robert muller even though he
had had unofficial ones for a while and
about a month later Roger stone was
indicted so does this signal that Donald
Trump jr. is going to be indicted Friday
F 5 Friday as many of known who have
become and as it be as it has become
known to many people probably not that
quickly but we could certainly see an
indictment of Donald Trump
Jr within 30 days of Robert Millar
getting those those transcripts could be
another big indictment Friday coming it
might just not be this Friday I was
actually kind of hoping for the
indictment today just hours before
Donald Trump State of the Union tonight
but clearly that isn't going to happen
could be 30 days could be 45 days but it
could be coming and it could get very
very bad for Donald Trump jr. sooner
than he might like that's for sure